okay so cor how did you how'd you get
into hacking well when I was younger I
always took things apart I'm the son of
an engineer so I always had tools around
the house at soldering iron stuff like
that take apart TVs and VCRs and just
figure out how things worked and I
remember my dad had this old 486 66 PC
you know it's like the first PC that I
started working with and learning like
just messing around with and that kind
of evolved into building my own machines
I was fascinated by just ordering the
different components motherboard Ram the
hard drive putting it all together and
it was a very painful process of like oh
I accidentally reformatted the wrong
partition and lost all my files or I
have to reformat because I infected
myself with some [ __ ] virus there so
it was a great learning experience of
just learning how hardware and software
worked and then by the time I was in
middle school I was more interested in
like breaking into systems and learning
how I wanted to be the cool hacker that
was portrayed and you know or what was
the media that you're consuming at that
point that you're like oh that's me all
right
I'm ashamed not ashamed it's a great
movie
okay I'm not ashamed ashamed is the
wrong word hackers was a big influence
wargames was a big influence yes so I
wanted to be that cool hacker guy that
knew more than you did when it came to
technology and computers so that was
like a driving force and my stupid
adolescent mind yeah okay and it was
cool though because I had that kind of
mindset of like how do things work I
want to figure out how things work and I
want to you know use systems in a way
that they weren't supposed to be used
for which is a definition of hacking so
to speak so I remember I would like get
in trouble on purpose in middle school
so I could go into the principal's
office because the Secretary's in the
principal's office when he waited there
we're using the computers to log into
this as400 system okay so I would talk
to them I would look at their screens I
would hover over
their shoulders and I'd get as much
information as I possibly could and my
first real tack since peak was in middle
school when I broke into this s400
system so is this like through the
school's intranet are you doing this
from home through the school's intranet
okay the only thing I didn't really do
anything from home until I started like
dialing into our library like we had a
public library that had a dial-up
service question so I could dial into
those servers but I did it from the
school intranet which was fun which was
awesome
didn't really cause any major damage
okay but what's interesting what were
you trying to do like change your
classic I just wanted to get in I don't
want to change anything I didn't want to
get caught I was really paranoid and
nervous about getting at how it just
wanted to get in okay getting in was
enough and it was awesome because years
later in the writers room for mr. robot
and you'll see this in season two I
think it's the fourth episode fourth or
fifth episode in the beginning where
there's this vo of Eliot talking about
his first major hack and he's like I
broke into my library's or my camera was
a library or school but I broke into
this as400 system using a vulnerable FTP
service and I'm like that's his first
hack and I was my first hack and it's
just fun to kind of incorporate that
into the show in that way so around that
time I would say middle school high
school I also really got interested in
prank calls and I would get together
with my friends and call different
businesses and personate different
people and really terrible way to to
spend your time and not really you know
not really thoughtful but it was it was
honestly a boot camp for social
engineering and I think I would like my
writer brain was attracted to the
character side of it and the narrative
side of it building out a story getting
the person on the other line to buy
whatever [ __ ] story that you're
feeding them and in this kind of weird
twisted sense of manipulation but that's
that's taking place but that was kind of
my foray into social engineering and was
it like social engineering for for
comedy sake like rank anchors for
comedies
yeah I was a huge fan of the Jerky Boys
alvars and yeah crank it crank anchors
came out around that time too so it was
just like getting a laugh or humiliating
the person on the other line or getting
them to have a funny response or a funny
reaction which in hindsight is stupid
but it but it taught me a lot because
you could use it I mean when you're
looking at it from a social engineering
perspective you could use it for the
goal of obtaining information or
obtaining any kind of protocol that you
know the person on the other end is
engaged and with whatever business
they're at so it really did help and if
Minh dove helped me in two ways helped
me within the hacker sense and it helped
me in the writing sense because it was
kind of like early improv classes were
just like developing character and
getting to the point getting your
information across and a short you know
three minutes span like why are you you
know you have you have a short amount of
time to get to to you know
achieve this goal so how are you gonna
spend it like what what's the dialogue
you're gonna use what's the plan what's
the game yeah
so it was interesting it was a lot of
fun and at that point do you realize you
know maybe I have a greater aptitude for
storytelling and like this is my passion
well it was it was weird I kind of I
around I didn't run both a lot of a lot
of my childhood alar yeah I still am
kind of it's weird but ever since I was
11 I knew that I wanted to write in
direct yeah huge film buff massive movie
collection was obsessed with you know
just just classic cinema and I told my
dad like this is what I want to do I
want to go to film school after I
graduate I'm had all planned out I go to
NYU Tisch nice School of the Arts and
going to learn how to really become an
auteur and he was like no waste a bunch
of money for you to end up some starving
you know bum on the street like you're
never gonna make yeah usually I mean he
was and I understand where he's coming
from like we both of my parents are
fairly conservative so he was like I'm
not gonna help pay for college for a
film school you're good with computers
you've always been good with computers
so go get a computer engineering degree
and at the time it was a huge rift
between my father
me because I really resented him for
that and I hated the idea of that but I
went down that path I studied computer
engineering for two years first few
years in college and then I got really
specific folk I got really specific
focus on network security which was
great and I remember like taking classes
just learning how to work with router
configurations and switches and there's
just one Linux security class where we
did like real Red Team Blue Team
simulations where like half the class
where the defenders and they had a Linux
box that they had to lock down and they
had like an hour to do so and then the
rest of the class or the Red Team and
like he gave us like a couple systems
and a Knoppix live CD and he's like go
to town you have an internet connection
and you have this CD trying to break in
ok so we would do this and then
afterward we'd share notes and talk
about different tactics what worked what
didn't work so it was a lot of fun and
it really helped because shortly after
that I ended up getting a cyber security
job for a major corporation and at that
point I was developing security policies
and you know working with like
enterprise level servers and doing
penetration testing and doing all that
stuff yeah while at the same time in the
back of my head I'm always like I always
knew like I'm not gonna spend the rest
of my life doing this mmm like I'm gonna
if I had to do this for the rest of my
life I would kill myself like I don't
want to be a corporate drone I never
wanted to be yeah so my plan was just
like live below my means save up enough
money I'm making good money working in
IT right keep writing keep making short
films try and make your own independent
films on the side learn as much as I can
and when the time comes pull the plug
and quit and switch jobs and get a job
in the entertainment industry and how
did you know when the time came because
this is like a very common thing across
tech people are like offered a great job
you know it's a cool company they're
interested in the work but maybe it's
not like they're calling how did you
know it was the point where you're like
alright this is it I'm doing it when I'm
actually gonna jump and yeah and do it
it was really just based on finances
okay I had a spreadsheet
and my girlfriend helped me like put
this together where you know if you save
this amount of money every single month
this is how much you'll have in your
bank account and like it's really a
question of how long could you go in the
entertainment industry and like how much
would you have to dip into your savings
and the way we calculated all the
numbers was like hey I could take an
unpaid internship for three years so I
saved up enough where I could three
years of work three years of working for
no income I would be fine and in my mind
I'm like alright if I can't make this
happen in three years then I'm not cut
out to do it and had you been in LA
already
I was already in LA so you're working
full-time I was working full-time doing
cyber security in LA moved from Michigan
to California knowing in the back of my
mind like alright it's gonna happen it's
gonna happen in LA so I should be closer
to LA and I was working out of Torrance
and I was living in Santa Monica at the
time and I just knew that I always knew
that in the back of my mind I wasn't
gonna stay there yeah and it was weird
it gave me this kind of freedom to like
this kind of apathetic attitude which
was I guess perceived as like confident
and and you know like I really know my
[ __ ] because I don't care about what the
out of this job or whatever and it did
really well for me like I end up doing
really well and moving up the corporate
ladder relatively quickly and in like
five or six years because of that
attitude which is really weird but it
did teach me a lot about just like how
you present yourself how you present
your ideas and helped a lot and you know
the writers room and and in different
aspects of my life it was a huge help
but yeah like once I realized like I
could I could I could I didn't giving
myself some time I'll do that mmm and
were your rear side projects finding
traction while you're working full time
well here's the thing I this is another
thing that was the address for it I had
a lot of content I had a lot of spec
scripts I was entering competitions I
was entering these fellowships I had
zero contacts I didn't know anyone in
the industry I didn't know any
assistance I didn't know any managers
and I know any agents so I was thinking
like alright I have all this stuff that
I want people to read maybe good maybe
bad a lot of it's bad
but I don't know anyone so the only way
I'm gonna meet people is if I make good
jump and start doing this so that's that
that's what I did and I made it a goal
that wherever I worked that I would like
try and expand my network as much as
possible and something that's
challenging for me because I'm I'm an
introvert like I don't really love to go
out and grab drinks or you know go to
social gatherings but I made it a point
like hey every other assistant that I
meet every other intern that I meet
every other you know anyone working in
this industry I want to get to know them
what they're working on what they want
to do and it really helped because it
really helped kind of like help me
navigate that this new kind of
unchartered territory of like where am I
gonna like what my next job is gonna be
in like if I look back on my career and
entertainment it's based on you know
some of those early relationships that I
made when I first made the jump and as a
fellow introvert like what were the most
effective tactics for getting it's like
transitioning into that media space and
yeah what are your pro tips okay so this
is super nerdy and weird and there's
something oddly in in the entertainment
industry there's something oddly
transactional about the relationships
and if you go into it kind of
understanding that like it's not to say
that it's they're insincere because you
obviously have friendships but there is
this kind of notion of we're gonna grab
drinks because at some point I can I can
help you accomplish your goal and you
can help you you know and I can you know
you can help me accomplish my goal
something something transactional in
that nature which isn't necessarily a
bad thing
so have that expectation going into it
and that's kind of what other people are
looking for in the in the exchange a lot
of the time and I had this spreadsheet
and I have a terrible memory but a lot
of spreadsheets I have a lot of
spreadsheets and charts so I had a
spreadsheet of like all right here all
the people here where they worked here's
what we talked about here is you know
the your the projects that they're
working on and here you know just like
just so I can kind of solidify it in my
mind so I don't embarrass myself because
it has happened to me before or like I
meet someone and then like six months
later I run into them again and I
introduce myself like oh no we already
and then I feel like a terrible person
yep okay this was trying to avoid that
and it's really just about making
yourself indispensable and wherever
you're at so whether it was an
internship for a production company or
whether I was an assistant for a
producer right so okay so wait yeah to
step back a little bit so you're just
some nerd and you're like I'm gonna make
movies then what do you start doing like
how do you get my first job was an
unpaid intern at a production company
where I along with a bunch of other
unpaid interns we sat in the basement
all day and read script submissions and
wrote something called coverage okay
which is basically a book report on a
screenplay okay so instead of an
executive having to read the entire
screenplay they read they read coverage
that was written by an intern or an
assistant and it's basically like a
two-page summary of the entire story and
then like a page of comments and
critiques okay
so my first day doing that I'm like this
is great this is awesome I get to read
and like critique scripts all day and
judge them it's awesome and then like
after a couple weeks I'm like I read
this is getting old exhaustion is
exhausting but in a weird way it
motivated me to because I'm like these
guys are working writers and some of
this is complete crap and it was
validating even though I was at the
bottom of the ladder okay it was
validating in some weird way that you
know if they can do it they can get
representation if they can make a living
doing this then gave me some hope like I
could do it too right so I did that for
a couple months
mm-hmm and I was able to turn that into
an assistant position so I finally
started getting paid even though I
wasn't getting paid money and that tape
that took like four months three or four
months which is a lot less than three
years which is great and I kept this
whole thing secret for my parents by the
way did not they thought I was still
working cybersecurity making six figures
amazing and I was making nothing and
then shortly after that I was making
like 600 hours a week yeah my Harris job
no benefits no nothing and oddly it was
very weird because when I told them both
my dad's reaction was acceptance who's
like fine you already did you already
a degree you can fall back on you have
contacts and you know in information
security you can always go back to that
you're single you're you're young you
don't have a family you don't many
people depending on you like this is the
time to go try this and my mom was super
pissed my shoes okay but the best quote
from that conversation when I finally
told her was me saying mom stop for
stressing about this you're making
yourself miserable and then she goes she
went I'm not making myself miserable
you're making she's like why would you
leave six figures and a you know a wish
you like the puppet master when you were
a kid you didn't realize it I don't it
was weird because she was always when I
was younger she was always supportive of
like my art projects or anything that I
creatively that I was passionate about
like whether I wanted to buy a musical
instrument or whether on to go do a
short film she was always on board my
dad was always like you know don't waste
your time too much because you're not
gonna make a living like go down this
sensible logical path and then it was
weird how they flip-flopped okay
but now she's fine okay yeah exactly
yeah success is like yeah all right fine
it's okay and so you eventually you
become this assistant and then you you
worked on a show that didn't work out
right okay
I worked on a couple of shows actually
just as assistants to producers
assistants to show runners and I ended
up I ended up becoming the showrunners
assistant to adam Fierro and Gina
Matthews and Grant sharbo or producers
of a show called rush that only lasted
for one season on USA but through that
experience I got to know the executives
and the assistants at USA really well
mm-hmm and shortly after that show kind
of died I grabbed drinks with one of the
executives at USA his name is Jake Stig
Leone great guy yeah and he was telling
me like we were just talking like you
and I are right now and I told him a
little bit about my history and you know
my previous career and that whole thing
and he was like all right I want you to
read this thing that we have that's
that's coming up from Sam s mail mr.
robot and let me know what you think so
he sends me this script I read it I love
it and they gave him my feedback and
then
within a month he sets up a meeting with
Sam and me because Sam was looking for
an assistant at that time and Sam didn't
know that I had a previous life as like
a cybersecurity you know
cybersecurity guy then basically what
Elliot did on the show was my old job
but this is what I'm trying to piece
together now cuz I knew some of your
history before we went up but like so
much of the show is just mirroring your
life right you're just this awkward guy
it's a weird serendipitous thing that
like because he wrote a pilot he wrote
the he wrote the pilot and shot the
pilot before I met him so I didn't work
on the pilot okay so he had already had
the pilot done yeah and he had just got
the series pick up so USA ordered a
season of television so he had to staff
a room and get a whole team together so
that was around the time where I met him
and I hadn't seen the pilot at that
point I had only read it and even
reading it I'm like alright this feels
like the perfect show for me hmm and
it's weird we were kind of talking about
this before I spent so much of my life
trying to leave the IT job and I don't
want to be known as the guy like don't
call me with your IT problems I don't
want to be that guy I'm a writer like I
want to go pursue my passion right and
it was weird with mr. robot those two
worlds just collided in the coolest way
possible because when I was talking with
Sam on it and I'm like hey I have done
all this before like I can help you
figure out we can make it Corp realistic
like we can do all these things and we
can have these different types of
attacks and like I think he we were both
really excited at the prospect they're
just like new in this kind of
partnership so you know worrying about
were you worried about coming on too hot
when you like you read it and you're
like oh my god this is the thing nah not
really
I was I mean of course with any meeting
like you always hope for the best and
you like personally I leave
second-guessing everything I said like
after this I'm gonna go home happen with
that but with that was it was pretty
quick like I got the news like shortly
after that meeting that we were gonna
move forward and that was really
exciting and it was great it felt like
it felt like I knew about
this magical thing that hadn't been
released to the world yet hmm
and in hindsight that is even a more
kind of important observation for me
because I knew that like based on my
taste my history that I was working on
something special and all throughout
season one when we were writing season
one when we're producing season one like
I knew that it was it was something that
was creative that was unique that
something was something that hasn't been
done before mm-hm so it was just so kind
of validating and satisfying to have it
be released and get the kind of
recognition that we got that like other
people got it and they were craving this
kind of you know hacker thriller story
did you get a sense because I like I've
worked on I mean even personally at
creative projects that you're like oh
this is good but it turns out it's good
for like a hundred people that are super
into it uh-huh was there anything that
signaled to you before it came out that
this would be interesting to like a
larger audience of folks that's why I'm
so captivated by this because most of
the time that's the case most of the
time I'll write something or I'll work
on something and I'll be like this is
awesome and then it doesn't get the
reaction yeah like people don't feel the
same way about it that I do and then I
start second like second-guessing myself
like is my taste off like was something
wrong it's just not the right timing or
you know what where where was the where
was the mishap right with mr. robot it
was one of those rare cases where like I
knew it was good and had it not been
successful I would have started to like
second-guess myself in a way it's kind
of like where you get into arguments
with people about like what their
favorite movies are and you know you
start second-guessing their tastes a
little bit but I knew that there are
people out there like me who wanted like
a very cool kind of stylistic character
piece about someone like Elliot mm-hmm
with the technology portrayed in a
realistic fashion which is something
that I I knew the community was was was
thriving for striving for and to be
honest I'm kind of surprised that hadn't
happened earlier there's so many
opportunities for it's happening it
always seems like a challenge like
making programming and even just being
in the terminal interesting that that in
and of itself is a difficulty one
that I want to talk about we were
talking about before is how you guys use
flash like because even just typing is
like unbelievably boring to watch
sometimes why do you guys use flash and
how do you do the on screen stuff so we
shoot everything practically on mr.
robot meaning we don't shoot green
screens we have burn anything in and
post me I like to put in plain terms in
plain team you're like you have a laptop
in like you're shooting over someone's
shoulder you see in the camera what they
see in really okay exactly real code on
the screens ready to go on the day of
filming yeah now in order to achieve
that we have to do suite we can't put
Rami in front of a terminal and give him
a list of commands that he asked to type
and you know risk spending the whole day
waiting for like him not to make a
syntax error you know you know I mean
just want to typos just one typo is
gonna basically ruin the shot yeah and
we don't have the time we don't have
like we've our like the schedule is
already crazy and you're like every
minute I don't know how many thousands
of dollars you're wasting of just
waiting for other things to happen on
set so my goal is to make sure
everything is as seamless as possible
and as foolproof as possible on the day
we're filming okay and the way we
achieve that is through flash animation
so I'll work closely with an animator to
create an interactive demo basically
where everything looks legit like it
looks like a real desktop environment it
looks like a real terminal window but
it's not it's all pre-programmed and you
can hit any keystroke you want and the
right the right code will show up on the
screen the right command will show up on
the screen and the only trigger to move
forward to the next screen is a special
keystroke so I'll be you know we'll make
sure we'll frame out the hands for this
specific shot and we'll set Rami down in
front of the computer and I'll just say
tight I'll be honest it'll be like type
and then I'll watch the screen and then
when it's right when it's like time to
hit Enter I'll say scream LLL scream hit
enter and he hits enter and then the
next screen shows up and that screen has
the pound sign in the in the prompt
because he ran some script and he ended
up getting rude on the box and then
that's the moment I'm like all right
you're in like let's wait here for a
couple minutes couple moments so it's
really
- its it's a necessity for just being
able to film like that yeah on the day
and I know people have complained before
like why are using flash and flash is so
outdated and it's just it's it's it's
what's available to us in terms of the
crew and you know the video playback -
Department and the anime animators who
are on the crew or who are on the show
just it's it's a close collaboration
with them to achieve like a
realistic-looking yeah copy well it
makes sense like in the interviews I've
heard from you in the past you're
spending weeks getting a lot of these
things done yeah and you know if you're
sick one day and you're not there to
watch him if you had to do this in real
life obviously it wouldn't like you
would shut the whole thing down yeah cuz
you just be over a shoulder saying like
ya know put a slash there put three dots
there there are times where I can't be
unset yeah I try and be on set as often
as possible but there are times where
I'm prepping for the next week's
animations so I can't be on set for this
day and I know it's only an easy it's an
easy app so he opens a laptop and it's a
lock screen he has to put in a password
and hit enter and unlock it and then
maybe one other action like he'll open
the terminal or oh he'll open Mozilla
Firefox with the mouse and I and if it's
something that easy like I know that he
can figure that out he doesn't need
hand-holding for that one and then on
the flip side there are super
complicated ones that took like three
months to build what's the most
complicated one so far season three had
a very complicated one which I don't
want to talk about yeah I should have
said but in season 2 I think it was the
the first scene in episode 204 so that
would be two point three and it's the
one I referenced earlier of him talking
with the voiceover about his first hack
and he has four terminal screen windows
open up he has exploit code in one
window he has an IRC chat with Darlene
he has you know he has a bunch of things
going on I think he's using he's
connecting to and on the inside using
tor that one took probably about two
months Wow and I have an amazing I don't
do all this by myself yeah I have an
amazing team of consultants that work
with me
Ryan Kazan seen Andre
McGregor and James Plouffe so oftentimes
I'll work with them to just really iron
out the details of what we're gonna see
what steps of the heck are we gonna see
cuz I don't want to we don't have time
to show everything we can only pick like
certain beats yeah like and I and like
to your point earlier I try and choose
the most interesting and most visually
appealing aspects of whatever attack
whatever the attack is so I'll work with
them to make sure the syntax is all
correct and get screenshots or video
recordings and we'll do it in a virtual
machine like a virtual machine
environment and like try and create it
ahead of time so I have as much content
as possible that can take to the
animator and be like alright just copy
this mimic this and then it's a whole
it's just like a script there's a whole
revision process with the animations of
like making sure there aren't typos
making sure the cursors are in the right
place is making sure the behavior of the
screens looks realistic because it's all
none of its real sure yeah so it's like
but the code compiles right like for all
this stuff I mean the code that we're
using yes but we're not gonna show we
never show enough for you to it's not in
structural it's not you wouldn't be able
to watch the show and be like oh I can
hack into a prison if f compromised the
PLC and open up the prison doors like
it's not gonna be like that but if you
do know if you are familiar with a
certain exploiters or like a good
example is I think it was 207 last year
early in an episode and one of the one
of the teasers we had Trenton hacking
Mobley's phone and she's a stage fright
and for a moment we show just a little
bit of stage fright what is that so for
people who stage for stage fright it was
a very popular Android phone an Android
script that was it was a huge
vulnerability that was disclosed a few
years back and luckily it worked for our
time table in the show which is a whole
nother thing we can talk about yeah so
like for something like that you would
know if you looked at if you just took
some of the lines of code and put them
into Google and searched that you would
find like some exploits for stage fright
and you would be able to like compare
that
and see that that's legitimate but
there's no way that you're gonna watch
that scene like you don't have enough
time and we don't have enough like
material to show you in the show that
you can go go off and do this about
yourself okay yeah because I've been um
I I think you mentioned one of the
podcasts that you were just watching old
like DEFCON talks for inspiration yeah
because you know as I've I'm up-to-date
now
I was wondering like are you guys
getting exhausting figuring out new ways
like invent the wheel well here's the
thing I and Ryan and I talk about this
all the time it's something that we
struggle with because we don't want to
keep reusing what we've already done and
there are new disclosures and new
vulnerabilities and new attacks that
come out all the time and there are new
exciting things and get showcased at Def
Con or other conferences and we want to
have a chance to use those so the way we
kind of get around it and justify it in
our heads are like alright maybe this
wasn't disclosed till 2016
maybe it wasn't disclosed till 2017 that
doesn't mean that the hole wasn't there
the bug wasn't that doesn't mean the bug
wasn't there to begin with
and it doesn't mean that someone like
Elliot could have had access to the
tools or the scripts or created them
himself
whatever whatever we need to service the
story and to use it so in in that sense
we kind of get around or digital but
kind of fudge it a little bit but in
terms of like I don't think there's ever
a concern of oh we're gonna run out of
ideas it just forces us to be more
creative about how are we going to
achieve this and and what are the
different layers of the attack and what
are the attack vectors and like you know
they're they're a bunch of different
ways to skin a cat and we can we can
change one aspect of it to make it feel
fresh and new and you know it's a great
example of that is like depending on you
know choosing which character we want to
use to to to to do certain acts like
Angela dropping a femtocell write an
evil Corp and then you know running a
command like that's not a big deal for
someone like le ater Darlene but we were
able to build a tense scene out of it
because it was Angela who was doing it
so it's always like there are different
ways to approach the scene and build out
the tension to make it feel fresh
and that's I mean it's not an easy thing
to do but it's something that we
struggle with all huh no but because
then you're trying to balance it out
like creating some weird MacGyver type
scenario where just like artificially
introducing these conflicts to work
around yeah it's a little bit it's a
little bit of both because sometimes
it's it's sometimes it would be
artificial like conflicts workaround and
a great a great example of this is
episode 105 okay and Elliott needs to
get into steel mountain and do the whole
raspberry pie hack like there are a
bunch of roadblocks that we put in front
of him and it was fun to kind of see how
he figures out to you know to get around
those and how Mobley and Romero are
helping him from the sidelines like
that's all fun stuff to mine right so it
can come from a bunch of different
places like is it gonna be MacGyver like
situations or is it going to be a
character conflict or is it gonna be
some kind of wound that the character is
dealing with it like it's making them
making making it very you know difficult
to get past this particular roadblock
and how are they gonna react and how are
they going to treat the situation like
that's what's fun about drama is like
you know punching your characters and
putting them in these really difficult
situations and seeing how they react
yeah and then how how have you dealt
with these hacks over time because again
like the show starts in 2015 right and
so how are you how are you managing to
even like acquire old versions of
software at this point it's becoming
more and more difficult every season um
super easy Season one because we were
like pretty close to our timeline season
two was more challenging season three
was very challenging and luckily we work
with different different companies the
company that we're working with to
create our cellphone animations how our
mobile apps they have a whole library of
old roms and old versions of software so
all I need to know is like all right
this thing exists in 2015 I can find
screenshots of it hopefully I can find a
YouTube video of it that's what it look
like so I can give them as much
information as possible okay find this
old ROM and just copy back like make
sure it looks exactly like that okay I
mean we use signal on the show yep and
you have signal on your phone now you'll
see it looks completely different than
the way it looks in 2015 yeah so I mean
it becomes it's kind of a pain but it's
it's it's fun to like stay authentic to
the time you know I do use flash of
videos on the phone as well are they
interfacing their flash apps on the
phone
oh really yeah okay man I need to get
into flash the only thing that you would
ever want to use flash for is working on
a television show like like mr. robot
but um yeah it's it's helped us
immensely in terms of just making it
easy for actors to like put put the
device in the actors hands and the
phones are easier because you know these
these guys have worked with phones
before so when I say like alright all
you're gonna do is reject the call like
they know what to do they all you're
gonna do is reject the call then you're
gonna open up this app look at it scroll
through it and then lock the phone okay
like that's a much easier conversation
than sitting next to Rami when he has
like a very complicated set of commands
that he needs to type into a terminal
you know terminal screen and right so
it's it's they're different they're
varying degrees of difficulty there you
know yeah but it seems like you have it
you have an added advantage as the as
the writer producer because previous
technical advisors I've talked to are
like they're like the hired gun that
comes in either in the beginning or the
end where it seems like at least like
you can push a little bit more weight
I've been wondering if there were
certain hacks that were just too
technical that you were trying to push
through all the time and okay all the
time we have examples that you talk
about here's the weird thing about
examples is there are things that I've
thrown out there that either will get
rejected outright or get saved for later
so like I don't want to get too
descriptive about something because I
know that there are things that we're
gonna like if we didn't use them in
season 3 or we're gonna use them in
season 4 we're gonna use them in season
5 but being a writer producer is
definitely a huge advantage on a show
like this because I'm there while we're
breaking the story I'm there pitching
out ideas I'm helping to write the
scripts and give notes on the scripts
and so I can always come at it from a
place of like being technically accurate
and saying like you know I'll let this
slide and I'll
choose my battles but something else
like I won't let this slide and I'll
fight to make this slightly different so
he keep it true - you know - how about
how it would be staged in reality so and
it's great because I'm there for every
day in the writers room I'm there on set
working with the animators working with
the whole crew and production and just
like right now I mean I'm gonna go back
to our post house to just where we're
editing season 3 so it's like it's it's
a cool it's cool to see it from
inception to completion and be a part of
it being able to kind of like make sure
that the technology and the accuracy is
still threaded through the narrative at
each step of the way whether that's
working with the actors to make sure
they're interacting with it correctly or
with the editors to make sure that
they're cutting it together in a way
that makes sense
you know what that being said season
three is coming up October 11 on us life
yeah that's the plug yeah okay so I'm
trying to order these questions mentally
kind of went through we jumped around a
lot I think we hit a lot of them but I
think so too
maybe we should just like go off on a
tangent then and talk about the argh the
alternate reality game derp that there's
a very active subreddit about yeah
explain it
yeah so basically and we really started
going crazy with this in season two have
any URL web address IP address host name
that you see on any of our screens any
QR code any bar code that you see
anywhere on the show in the frame of mr.
robot will lead you somewhere and it
will lead you to a puzzle possibly it'll
lead you to an experience that may mimic
what you see on the show or in that
scene it'll it'll lead you to something
that feels like it's a part of the story
and more often than not that puzzle is
part of a larger meta puzzle which is
our Arg mm-hmm and it's really it's a
really fun aspect of my job takes a lot
of work to prepare
and the folks at USA Digital are our
great collaborators with me on this and
we just we just added Ryan Clark and his
team at curious codes and who does the
the badge challenges at DEFCON huh it's
been he's been a puzzle master for years
so he we brought him on board and okay
during season two which has been a great
collaboration between all of us and it's
it's really satisfying to see the
response on the subreddit response on
Twitter and just watch them like
watching them figure out these puzzles
and working together and sharing
information it's like this open source
hacker mindset at work but it's all
about our show and it's this love this
is level of interaction between us and
them which is fantastic it's great and
it's just so it's one of the most it's
one of the most satisfying aspects of my
job just watching that play out it's so
much fun I once heard that the the
writers have lost were actually I mean I
think loss is before reddit maybe maybe
exemplary I think so I'm not sure yeah I
regardless they were going on forums of
some kind and reading about the
conspiracy theories and then including
elements of that in the show later on
are you guys getting involved in that
way like it's a baby me it's about as
much as I can say okay maybe all I know
and they know this because I've seen
them post about it I read all that I
read almost everything okay so whether
or not it's being incorporated the only
time will tell but we definitely read it
so we are watching and listening well is
so I've never interacted with the show
in this way um are the puzzles
cumulative like first season - for
example like was it working towards some
goal at first it didn't feel like that
when if you start playing so you'll
you'll solve a puzzle
and you'll get a password or you'll get
a quote and that'll be the end of that
kind of puzzle right does he tell you
it's the end it it doesn't sometimes it
does sometimes it depends on what you're
doing okay
and then at the very end there's this
kind of grand puzzle that kind of hints
at like hey you need to go back
find whatever the quote was for that you
found at the end of this puzzle from
season two and put that in here
and do the same thing for a bunch of
other pieces of the puzzle that were
spread out like peppered throughout the
season okay to unlock this greater meta
puzzle so that's about as descriptive as
I want to get with it because I don't
part of the fun is just having them
figure it out because these guys are
brilliant guys and girls of course and
you know it's just so much fun to see
them see them work on it well they do
have a couple questions for you so we
will see what you can answer yeah yeah I
know no comment on all this okay so rou
asks where do things stand with the
season 2 Arg winners did we miss a clue
to continue or things still being put in
place for them the season 2 Arg winners
we have something in store for you guys
and that's about as much as I can say a
short pause will be this part of it we
were there any moments where you felt
that the Arg wouldn't be solved at the
moment that sticks out to me is the
kernel panics we should explain they
seem like they would never get to the
bottom of them it's funny that he
mentions kernel panic because that was
one that I thought would get solved a
little bit earlier than it did okay and
it was just the sequence where we
flashed like a frame up a piece like a
bunch of different screens like crash
screens of like a Linux system crashing
and if you found the right character on
each of those screens in order it would
lead you to another URL oh my god okay
so there are a little there's a very
subtle hint about where that character
was like over many spaces across and
however many lines down you had to go in
order to find that character on all the
screens and then put it all together but
it's just white text on a black
background yes it's not okay yes but a
bunch of different screens flash so
that's what he's it took them months to
figure that out but it was cool because
like I was asked about it when it was
going on - and I'm fine with it taking
as long as it is long as it's gonna take
like even if even if it doesn't even if
it takes
year I think that's there's something
fun about that and something like
immensely satisfying when it finally
does happen right yeah and the day that
it got solved like we were celebrating
too it's fun for us it was so much fun
too and sometimes we'll go on Twitter
and like drop little hints here there
will go on the subreddit and we'll drop
little hints but not often and on the
flip side there are some there's some
that we were like alright it's gonna
take them forever to figure this out and
then they crack it in like two hours
like it's it's hard to gauge but it the
kind of volatile nature of it is fun
yeah yeah it's uh yeah well because I
mean have all any admit you're probably
won't gonna answer this one but have all
the Easter eggs been found in even
season one season one yes okay
season 2 and season 3 I cannot talk
about for now next question how did you
feel about our progress through the
season to Arg give a report card I feel
very proud and happy for you guys
and I don't want to say too much but
I'll say that an update is coming fairly
soon about this season to Arg okay
that's all that's all I'll say it's very
unclear answers you're like wading
through all this like we don't want to
hear the boring [ __ ] about his
background get to the energy stuff and
then now they're cursing my name yeah
and then meanwhile the other people are
sending up telling the opposite way BK
an apple I could guess that means
Brooklyn Apple asks how is the air or
has the arg 3.0 meaning for season 3
begun or are we jumping the gun maybe
maybe it has begun all right let's get
the other questions there's a strong
possibility but maybe not who knows if
it hasn't begun it'll start soon yeah
October 13th October 11 that's October
11th season 3 what time I believe it's
at 10:00 p.m. not sure you can stream
online yeah you can see remind - ok so
on USA sorry oh yeah
king of the wild front has any new
attack method giving you ideas for
things that could be incorporated into
the show um similar to what we were
talking about earlier it's like we're
always on the lookout for new attack
methods and new tools and tool sets and
you know we're keeping an eye on
different disclosures and exploits and
the real like only challenge that we
have is that whole timetable at that
time table yeah which I guess you sort
of fudge because it could be like
private exactly we sort of fudge because
okay maybe it was not disclosed at that
time but you know hackers were still
aware of it or the community look at
certain members of the community we're
aware of it and we can just say that
Elliott and F society you know we're
aware of it at that time because they're
awesome hackers yeah so in that sense we
try and incorporate some of the newer
developments in that world in the tech
world into the show and then that way
are you ever jealous of shows like Black
Mirror that get to play with near future
technology all the time just it's weird
it's a I have a I'm conflicted about it
it's like a love-hate relationship
because it's such a pain in the ass to
like get all this right real then do it
real but it's so satisfying when you see
that these details are being noticed and
people are tuning in and they're excited
by the real portrayal that you know the
realistic portrayals we have on the show
so that's extremely satisfying that
makes it all worthwhile but when you're
in the thick of it when you're doing it
you're like wasting not wasting but the
ending like three months on this drink
trying to build out this desktop
environment in the sequence and make
sure every last character is no J you're
thinking like oh it'd be so much easier
if we were in like you know 2099 and
like we could play with whatever we
wanted and add some kind of [ __ ] to
the screen yeah I still based in reality
but not doesn't have a reference point
it doesn't have something that people
can go look up and be like oh you
screwed up right you this is this is not
what this looked like so that's another
fear I have all the time whenever we're
airing episodes I'm watching Twitter and
I'm watching ourselves and I'm like all
right what are they going
catch what are they gonna do is always
gonna be something gonna be something
you can't please everyone you know did
my team screw up did I screw up and I
mean most of the time it's positive most
of the time it's good like our fans are
awesome yeah and the fact that they're
nitpicking on that level is a testament
to like where we are which is great so
like if you're nitpicking like just a
line of syntax I'll or a line of code
but everything else is kind of alright
for you like that's fine at least it's
not you know some of the other offenders
of like hacking into the Department of
Defense in under 60 minutes or under 60
seconds you know something like that so
it's not it's nothing compared to what
people have been used to for the past
you know I don't know what two decades
now easy yeah I think it for me it
always feels like someone cares about
you like if they're gonna go to that
level of nitpicking and they like the
show and they're you know yeah yes and
there are core fans and they want to I
mean they want to but also I get it
because part of like the hacker psyche
and part of just IT people in general
because I have a little bit of this too
it's like all right you think you guys
are good
let me show you where you're wrong right
I'll show you what what the real case is
like what the real situation is yeah
which is fine okay a couple more
questions
so Rohan saw no Hwanhee I'm
mispronouncing people's names every
single time is the code used in in the
show actually functional in real life if
someone were to be hacking into
something kind of talked about yet
earlier two-degree yes yeah and again
it's just snippets of code we're not
going to show you every single step but
if you were to look up if you were to
just screenshot a bit of our code or a
bit of source code that's on one of the
screens and research it you'll be able
to find it I'm github you'll be able to
find it somewhere in its entirety but
then again if you don't know what you're
doing you're not gonna be able to really
use it yeah so it's it's not like we're
ever gonna show every single line of
code for for an exploit on screen but
we'll show you know we'll show we always
have characters running custom-made
scripts we show the output of those
scripts we show
you know different tools on the phone we
should we like showing pieces of
hardware that can be used in a certain
way to either compromise the system or
you know get data off of a card whether
it's like an RFID card or RFID chip
something like that so we try and make
sure that everything is based in reality
as much as possible okay do you ever um
Jerry a jealous when like certain things
come out now and you're just like man I
wish we could just jump like two years
ahead and have this technology so we
could use this exploit yes happens
sometimes
and the most recent thing in my memory
isn't even an exploit it's just just
just like technology in general
wearables and Internet of Things and to
Apple face thing yeah okay all these
things like that would be so much fun to
incorporate in the show and play with
that we are kind of off limits until our
timeline catches up yeah definitely
definitely but again like back to our
back to that earlier thing like if it's
something that could potentially like
really be reasonably sold as 2015 then
I'm all about exploring it you know oh
yeah this one was just kind of a random
random question John Coogan asks what
precautions do you take when using
devices so I'm super paranoid all the
time I enable two-factor authentication
and all my services whenever it's
available I would advise people to use
password managers use I use a VPN
religiously regardless of where I am I'm
always using the VPN on the phone as
well on my phone as well but definitely
regardless of what you use make sure
it's a like do some research and make
sure it's you know usually though the
ones that you pay for are the better
ones some of the free VPNs are kind of
or not they're not so great I think
people have difficulty with this stuff
because so many companies have figured
out how to game SEO again so they're
like I don't know what's legit yeah let
me download some crazy malware on their
computer totally it's already so I mean
that's why I'm like there is a level of
research that has to go into it before
you you decide to to invest in one and
to use it but it's totally like I don't
whether I'm at a coffee shop or at an
airport or even if I'm at home or the
off
I'm always using one okay um you take
your camera I don't
oh it was interesting I don't because I
think it's annoying
I don't think that I'm not I want to
dissuade other people from doing it
because I think it's a good practice but
my mindset is like if someone has access
to my camera they already have access to
my microphone they already have access
to my files so I'm already [ __ ] right
so I have a process running an app that
just tells me whenever any other program
on the machine is trying to arm the
microphone or is trying to use the
webcam so I get an alert at least okay
what are you concerned about in terms
you know like everything a software no
right like are you concerned about your
microwave being hacked your self-driving
car you've a Tesla have a Tesla so I'm
not concerned about that I am most
concerned about companies that have my
private information my personal
information yes and how they store it
like the Equifax examples it was a great
one like they have a duty to ensure that
the security around that information is
sound and is very bust and I think
that's kind of just a contract that you
enter and with any kind of business when
you're giving up that kind of level of
personal information so that's what I'm
worried about I'm worried about other
companies not patching their software
and you know having just security holes
and vulnerabilities that get exploited
and those data leaks happen mmm okay
you will then you're in a perfect
position evil Corp right yeah so with
every podcast now we have a crypto
question Alchemist prime asked just what
you think in general but I think it's
somewhat related right because people
talk about coins and distributed file
storage and all that kind of stuff do
you guys pay much attention to that I
know evil Corp has a coin evil Corp has
a coin yeah which we'll learn more about
when you watch the show we talk about
Bitcoin a lot on the show so crypto
currencies are part of one of the the
plot lines along with the whole evil
Corp Phillip price storyline yeah
personally I think blockchain is
unbelievably exciting and I think it's
the future so I am all for people
investing in crypto currencies investing
in Bitcoin aetherium
it is a volatile market right now and
you have ICO is coming out every day and
that takes some research as well make
sure that you have a good team behind it
and that they're actually working hard
and and and doing what they need to do
and it's not just just scam like a pump
and dump scam but I am all for it and I
think it's I think it's the wave of the
future and just just the blockchain
technology itself is exciting to me so
I'm all about it and I love that we
incorporate some of it into the show if
anything just to put the question out
there and lay the lay person's mind like
oh what is Bitcoin or what is a
cryptocurrency and if they want to go
online and research it and whether they
think that it's something that is
hearsay or not like I just love that
it's it's creating a conversation out
there so I'm proud of that yeah I mean
it seems that like you guys are you
doing the job of transferring this idea
of like the hacker community to I mean
millions and millions of people it just
hope so I hope so that's uh I mean part
of the challenge that I always run up
against is like how can I make something
like this digestible for millions of
people and how can I make them
understand it and if they don't
understand it how can I make it still
entertaining for them and still service
all those people who do understand it so
it's just this is it's this
give-and-take of like how much tech
jargon are you gonna put into the scene
how much you know how much time are we
going to spend explaining this stuff and
how much are we just gonna kind of gloss
over and just assume that you know our
viewers or a really smart can put two
and two together and we can just move on
yeah so yeah that's why you never have
someone on mr. robot explaining exactly
what bitcoin is but you have Phillip
price talking about equine and talking
about how they're in control of the
ledger and how it differs from Bitcoin
because no one's in control it's a big
one because it's complete decentralized
so we try and find a way to make it work
for the narrative without kind of
spoon-feeding
exposition - you had a challenge how do
you keep your chops meanwhile like
obviously you're all consumed with this
show yeah it seems like we're 11 months
of the year I said how do you keep your
technical chops I do my best to try and
read up on tech blog
blogs goto to conferences and try and
read as much as possible but at some
point I can't keep up and that's where
my team comes in like that's where I
talked to Ryan or James or Andre and I
call them up or text them and be like
hey we want to do something for this
situation what do you think okay we have
any grand ideas and it's a lot of times
they do well then I have kind of two
more questions to wrap up we a lot of
people who listen to the podcasts are
just getting started a lot of other
people who listen to the podcast or
thinking about transitioning their
career at some point if someone wants to
get started in hacking what should they
do and if someone wants to get started
in writing for TV what should they do
okay for hacking I would definitely
watch youtube videos listen to the
hacking podcasts out there read as many
books as you possibly can like right now
it's such a prime time for just getting
access to information yeah it's easier
than it's ever been so you can read
about it you can watch videos you can go
to conferences go to Def Con or if you
can't go watch watch the videos on
YouTube and just try and educate
yourself and it's a lot of like you know
self-motivated problem-solving huh so
once you figure out once you learn more
about it generally you can kind of focus
in on you know what what about it is
appealing to you is that web application
security is it perimeter security is it
you know whatever whatever really floats
your boat in the hacking world once you
get involved in it you'll be able to
kind of you know decide that for
yourself and for writing two things
right as much as possible are you doing
like a daily session or how do you I
used to ever since I worked on the show
I don't anymore because a lot of my time
is devoted to the show but figure out
whatever your process is everyone's
process is different whether you write
late at night early in the morning and
what's important is like even if you
don't feel like it it's the last thing
you want to do just force yourself to do
it it's not like oh I'm only gonna write
when I'm inspired it's like I'm gonna
force myself to do this every single day
and so human kings book highly
recommended I'm writing yes great avoid
adverbs because they're terrible yeah
and then in terms of just like getting a
job in the industry as a television
writer
I would say look at into internships and
try and get an internship try and learn
as much as you can try and make yourself
indispensable at every company that you
end up at try and just try and get your
work out there and try and hone your
craft and get better move to LA would
you recommend that definitely I would
move to LA if you want to be a TV writer
yes if you want to be a novelist you can
stay wherever you're at but if you want
to be a TV writer I would say move to LA
okay all right
any teasers for season three I can say
this that season three a major theme of
season three is disintegration so we are
going to see Elliot and robot separated
in some in a very cool way that we
haven't seen before
so that'll be interesting just watching
this battle play out between Elliot and
mr. robot so it's a wild ride man these
episodes are coming together and it's
really excited for everyone to see it
that's so cool all right thanks thank
you
you